two weeks ago Lea Michele stepped onto
this stage for the first time as Fanny
Bryce and received not one not two but
six standing ovations well deserved she
burst into tears as the crowd in these
very seats left to their feet and I was
lucky enough to be one of them alongside
of her mother her father
her husband and father of her child and
hundreds of fans
please welcome funny girl Leah Michelle
I'm crying how
oh my gosh let's talk we've got so much
to talk is this me this is you I think
these are from the show they certainly
are I'm glad you noticed how was my how
is my family with you well okay a funny
story
um at the end
I was crying really hard and I was
sniveling but there was a gentleman
behind me who was crying too was it my
father it was your father I found out
and I was relieved because he was giving
me permission yeah to feel my feelings
only to meet him
after the show and realize it was your
father my dad I know my my father was so
emotional he was so nervous to see the
show that I he was like maybe I
shouldn't sit in the seats maybe I
should just Pace in the back of the
theater during the show you're like that
might be good or not I'm not sure but I
actually I I sat at the desk at the top
of the show
and I started singing the first
few notes of the first song
and I immediately heard my best friend
Jonathan hysterically crying and I was
like oh my God I was like he's gonna cry
the entire show so it was it was really
emotional for for for everyone I think
and I was thinking this morning it's so
cheesy but you know he was saying the
song in the show we sing people who need
people are the luckiest people and I and
I had my people you know here to see me
not only my family my best friend but
the support of fans and people who have
you know been following me throughout
the years and especially the Glee fans
Ryan Murphy was right there Ryan was
there you know this is so much of a
journey for Ryan and I as well
you know how he brought funny girl into
people's homes and and introduced Fanny
Bryce to that generation and now Michael
Mayer bringing the show back and
introducing it to this generation it's a
show that I love so much as everyone
knows and I'm just so grateful that it's
here on Broadway and and that the world
gets to to know funny girl when you
walked out
you know it's the night of September 6th
you see the crowd of people what is the
first thing you think when you walk out
on that stage all I kept saying to
myself on September 6th was I'm just so
excited as an actor to get to tell this
story and to perform and to sing I
haven't performed in a really long time
and especially on a stage and there's
nothing like it it's exhilarating it's
like therapy for me it really is now you
come out
and you're this ingenue
who nobody knows yet
are you thinking
okay this is a bookend I'm going to come
out here
I have a mission and I'm gonna stick
that Landing in a way that's going to be
different
than anyone expects and I know I've got
a whole mountain to climb to get there
I've never had the opportunity to play a
character like this before that has such
a complete and full Journey but the fact
that you can take her from beginning
middle to end and end triumphantly it
gives that that that strength to go okay
I've told her story now I can sort of
breathe and have the energy to then do
it again
you know the next night and the next day
and the next day and there's so much of
this role that does mirror my life and
feels rings so true to me
and that's why I couldn't have played
this part at any other point in my life
at any other phase in my life because
it's the journey and it's the
experiences that I'm taking into every
word and every step of this that's it
when they called me that I that I got
this part for you know for doing it now
I was at an Italian restaurant with my
father and my son just like literally
doing the mom thing you know where it's
like just kind of trying to rush the
dinner to get the baby home to put him
in the bath and I was like
the food wasn't coming on time and and
then my phone was ringing and I was like
Dad I was like you just got to get the
baby to eat some of this pasta because
we got to get home we got to put him in
the bath and uh and I picked up my phone
it was my my agents and they said you're
gonna be Fanny Bryce on Broadway and I
just I if I could have fallen to my
knees on the side of the street I would
have and funny enough one of my dear
friends Gideon from Spring Awakening
just happened to be passing me on the
street and saw me and he knew he just
instinctually knew that I was getting
the call and he took pictures of me and
he has these pictures really just
standing on the corner like oh I was I I
was so happy
and I'm here now and
and here now as a mom and a wife living
back in New York on Broadway playing
this role you know for me it just feels
this timing was right for me
when you met your husband and you know
your child's father were you like this
is who I can do this with I mean at
first I was like I I we were friends for
for a while at first we met at our Best
Friend's Wedding he was friends with the
groom and I was friends with the bride I
mean
I know it's very cute
um but it's like I just couldn't see
things clearly
it was all about my career you know I've
been so career focused my entire life
um I think to a fault I think that I had
you know just this the sense of drive
that created a lot of blind spots for me
in my life and then when I met my
husband like I said it was a real sense
of grounding for me and then having our
son and and and experiencing the
challenges that we did throughout the
pregnancy was something that you know
unfortunately created a stronger bond in
us that I would never wish on anybody
but but it but it did and um but the
fact that we were able to sort of get
through all of that and and how it then
transformed us into this new life here
and when you're given a great
opportunity as I have been with this
which I'm so incredibly grateful for as
a performer as a person uh I just feel
like
what I do now with this is on me and how
I handle this and I'm really ready to
take all of this on and
and do a great show every night but also
have fun with my cast
come home and celebrate with my family
which is something I never did before
and I'm really enjoying being able to
open my eyes to everything that's going
on around because it's all good and if
it's not fun then why do we do it I
think you make such a good point
[Music]